twisted and broken Carriage is derailed
these are the remains of a Greek train
after one of the deadliest crashes in
decades
it was just before midnight near the
city of Larissa when an Intercity
service collided with a freight train in
the dark passages described panic
screaming
an impact which they say felt like an
earthquake
four of the carriages came off the
tracks before several caught fire
the first sight was scary because there
were many big pieces of Steel the trains
were completely destroyed both the
passenger and freight trains the
passenger train was going about 160
kilometers per hour and there was a
clear head-on collision
people were scared very scared actually
they were looking around searching they
didn't know where they were
the passenger train had been traveling
from Athens to Thessaloniki when it
happened as Rescuers try to free the
reported 350 people on board the Army
has been called into hell
many of the injured are being treated in
Larissa with two other hospitals on high
alert
it's still too early to say what caused
this crash one of the worst in Greek
history